hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll so
physics
it's in a crisis have you heard that
have you heard the physics in crisis
we're in trouble because we haven't
found new particles super symmetry and
string theory and dark matter have been
proposed as these wonderful theories but
no experimental evidence has yet been
brought forward that these might be on
the right track we are lost in our own
thoughts sitting in our armchairs rather
than confronting the reality of the
world in a direct way or so we are told
i don't think it's quite that simple i
don't think the physics is in a crisis
but there is something really really
interesting from the kind of history of
science point of view about the present
moment in fundamental physics in
particle physics and cosmology namely
that we are really really good at
explaining the data you know we have
theories the standard model of particle
physics the core theory general
relativity the standard model of
cosmology we're almost too good we have
these theories that fit all the data we
have but also we think we have really
good reason to believe that these
theories are not the final answers it's
easy to come up with questions we can
ask these theories don't provide
sensible answers to so that puts us in a
bit of a pickle in terms of how to make
progress right i mean we would like to
build bigger and more powerful
instruments to probe the natural world
whether they be particle accelerators or
observatories dark matter detectors etc
but we don't know exactly what we're
looking for so where are we
why aren't we somewhere else
are we driven to questions like the
multiverse and the anthropic principle
is it okay to be driven there or is it
somehow embarrassing to be driven there
that's what's on the table today we have
as our guest michael dine an extremely
distinguished particle theorist uh
michael is maybe the leading person over
the last few decades at taking ideas
from big picture questions about string
theory super symmetry etc and connecting
them to
experiments things that we can try to
observe in accelerators or elsewhere as
he will very very quickly admit we don't
have the data that we would like to have
had so he hasn't you know made a
prediction that has come gloriously true
but he's a very very reasonable guy you
know michael is very optimistic about
particle physics in general but he's
also absolutely willing to admit that
there are challenges ahead of us to
admit that string theory for example or
supersymmetry as successful as they are
intellectually haven't lived up to the
promise of their early years and maybe
that's a reason to rethink a little bit
but of course as he would say
give me your better idea and then i will
start rethinking so we have a long
conversation that goes into a lot of
what is the big landscape of issues
confronting particle theory and
fundamental physics more generally in
the modern era where we are where we
hope to be how we might move forward
covering a lot of different possible
ideas it's it's a very good overview
that should give everyone a balanced
picture of what is in the mind of most
working
quantum field theorists particle
physicists fundamental physicists and i
say that very carefully because of
course
the public view isn't always the insider
view you're getting the insider view
today not everyone agrees because this
is you know still academia still science
we disagree with each other but you're
getting what basically is the closest to
a consensus view
of what state particle theory and
fundamental physics is right now feel
free to disagree of course michael is
very clear when he doesn't even know
what the answer is himself but we'll
learn about what that state is maybe
give us some clues for going forward if
you want more depth and details here's a
new book just out this way to the
universe a theoretical physicist journey
to the edge of reality so let's go
do
michael dying welcome to the mindscape
podcast very good to see you sean i
thought we would start simple uh down to
earth
tell me what is the state of elementary
particle physics today
how would you summarize it in a few
words well of course that's uh
you know i wrote a whole book about this
but what i would say is that
it's in one sense in a remarkably good
state
uh we know an awful lot a lot of things
that were seen well beyond us 20 30
years ago
you know
we have also many questions
some of them are things that we are
likely to know answers to
in the foreseeable future
some
maybe longer and some possibly never
and and and it's that and there there's
some tension there in that kind of
division
there's attention and
what will we really know what are the
questions we should be asking what are
the questions we'd like to ask that's a
great good kind of what i see as the
status now well it's a remarkable
success story right i mean um the whole
framework of quantum field theory
uh which we now take for granted as the
the right way to describe elementary
particle physics there was a time in the
60s maybe even the early 70s when people
were doubtful about that but then it
eventually triumphed
oh absolutely you know one of the things
i talk about a little bit i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm still hearing your alerts
yeah let's see they're quite loud let me
repeat that and i'll and i i'm sorry i
have not been able to suppress this
properly
one of the things i talk about in the
book
a bit is that when i started out as a
graduate student
quantum field theory was still just a
little bit on the edge
um there were other ideas around
string theory in its first incarnation
uh proposed a whole different way of
looking at elementary particles than
quantum field theory
and
and there was still a lot of interest in
the subject
so it was just at that point that
the standard model with its various
features were was
was taking off
and
it wasn't totally established then so
that's certainly something that that's
changed and
and all
all of uh
you know we've gone from
very
tentative understanding to precision
understanding
of the strong interactions the weak
interactions the electromagnetic
interactions
and that's certainly not something that
we envisioned
in say the mid-1970s when i was kind of
starting out well we don't have to go
into i think um like listing all the
particles and forces but it's important
to get on the table i guess that
there is a set of particles and forces
that we think is more or less
internally complete right maybe there's
more particles and forces that we
haven't found but you know there's
there's none out there that we say oh we
need this one ingredient to make things
make sense
that's right so it so in some sense we
uh so so i should back up and say
that
as an example
uh
well first i should say that there are
sort of
three forces that we deal with commonly
in experiments the strong the weak and
the electromagnetic force
okay uh and those forces
we've come from
this very tentative understanding 40
years ago say
to a very precise understanding now
and that's in some sense a good and a
bad thing
it's a it's a great thing and then since
we have this understanding
for working scientists it's a it's a
it's a puzzle everything works almost
too well we have questions
and it's not clear we have good clues to
the answers so i think that's that's uh
that that's again it's sort of tension
that uh
i think i tried to deal with in this
book
that um
you know what what is it we understand
what is it we don't understand and what
are the clues we have to to answering
the questions we don't understand we
certainly don't know everything
but we know an awful lot
yeah i mean sometimes the way i put it
is we have a theory that fits all the
data and we know the theory is not right
and that's a very frustrating position
to be in as working scientists i think
that's a very good way to put it yes
i might borrow that slogan from you
please please do
and i mean maybe again for the people
who are not experts in this uh let's try
to make sense of the discovery of the
higgs boson because that was a big you
know in 2012 on the one hand a
tremendous amount of anticipation it all
worked yeah the large hadron collider
did a great job on the other hand there
was a sense in which we expected it and
would have been much more surprised not
to have found it so i mean how do you
think about that achievement
10 years ago well
um
in a sense it this for for me this well
there are two aspects of this
one is that so basically in the in the
mid-1960s
stephen weinberg and abdul salam wrote
down a
theory of the weak interactions with a
particular structure for the higgs
particle okay there was no that they
just simply they did the simplest thing
one could hope to do
uh there was no particular good reason
that that should work yeah
and there's been a lot of angst in the
subsequent years about
whether that whether that would be right
whether
whether it should be that simple
whether really you might expect some
more complicated
sort of story
uh and
so in a sense what's
uh
it's remarkable that that simple story
which has various peculiarities it
raises some of the questions which you
and i have sort of alluded to now
uh that that simple story works
so from my perspective that's what's
really striking
so i have colleagues for example who
work on
the question of
both experimentalists and theorists who
work on the question
of additional higgs particles could
there be more
uh what is what is
what is true about that is if that were
to be the case that's really weird
that in terms of the kind of puzzles
that we have about the standard model
it's weird enough that there's this one
simple higgs okay and if there were more
that would be that would be really
striking
uh so um
so i tend not to be a enthusiast for
these possibilities but i do
sort of view them as well if there were
discovery it would turn my world around
maybe one thing that that would be worth
uh remarking on uh or
i would love to get your your insight
into is
uh when we talk about the standard model
of particle physics we're excluding
gravity from that sometimes following
frank wilcheck i i lump in gravity and
call it the core theory because we
understand quantum gravity in the weak
field regime pretty well
but of the three forces that we know the
electromagnetic the weak and the strong
um they're all in different phases as
as quantum field theorists call them
right the coulomb phase the higgs phase
the confinement phase talk about i'm
assuming that the people in the audience
don't know what those words mean
necessarily but talk about what those
words mean and is it interesting or
provocative to you that the different
forces are uh manifesting themselves to
us in different phases
um well i should say for me personally
this is very interesting i want to say a
few words i'll say a few words about
this so for me personally what i was
keeping me
awake
nights these days is exactly question of
of of this phase structure and in
particular the phase structure for the
strong interactions
so
again this sort of takes us back again
to my graduate student days and all the
things that have happened subsequently
so um
in in my graduate student days people
understood or felt they understood
the electromagnetic force which as you
say is something in the in a coulomb
phase it's a
it's the phase which means basically
that we have
charged particles they repel each other
if they have the same charge they
attract if they have the opposite charge
um all those features are sort of
familiar and in very and we understand
this in very detailed ways and
with quantum mechanics and quantum field
theory right so so that story understood
in the in the late 60s uh we have this
development of this story of the of the
higgs phase which is the phase of the
weak interactions
um and
uh and we and that there we understand
that
the
the gauge fields the particles that
inter that
that mediate the forces
the force
are heavy and that's in contrast to the
coulomb phase of qed where of quantum
electrodynamics where the photon is
massless and the photon we know is
massless to an extraordinary extent it's
full you know and and it's certain you
know it's certain at some point people
believe that was forced on you by
questions of principle and the higgs
particle so the higgs really was
discovered by a gang of six yeah uh
higgs name got attached to it for his
you know historical reasons
uh the
um
the
but what but they discovered is a
mechanism by which
these force carriers can be heavy
the
um
the strong interaction in
in
those in those days in the 70s was even
a bigger
puzzle
because
uh you know so so people predicted the
existence of quarks
and the quarks uh had forces mediated by
these particles called gluons
okay which should be massless
and then the question is why didn't you
see the quarks these fractionally
charged particles and why didn't you see
the gluons and so in those days people
started talking about something called
confinement but somehow the quarks
weren't visible and this sounded
preposterous a sort of excuse
for for something and i think even those
who said these words were very
uncomfortable
with the situation
that's changed a lot we've understood
the that this sort of confined phase
of a quantum field theory is a real
phase of the theory
and we have
various tests we have theoretical tests
on paper with paper and pencil but we
also have numerical simulations very
elaborate numerical simulations
so-called lattice gauge theory
computations
which uh
which verify this feature this confining
feature
and there's inter they're interesting
relations between the
confined phase and the higgs phase in
particular because in both cases you
don't have a massless
force carrier that you can see
so sometimes these phases are really
kind of opposite sides of the same thing
so this is again something where there's
been enormous progress and again
something which keeps me awake nights is
trying to understand
and absorb some of the results of the
numerical studies of the of the computer
simulations
of the strong interactions which at this
point
which again in in in the 70s were in a
very primitive stage both because
computers were primitive compared to
what we have now and also because the
algorithms and the theoretical
understanding
was much poorer and the level of
sophistication now
is quite extraordinary i mean
the lattice people not only
verify things we sort of think should be
true
but they predict new things and a new
phenomenon it's a good point because
it's something that's hard to appreciate
maybe from the outside because in the
early 70s
people like you say would say things
like oh they're these new particles
called quarks and they're held together
by particles called gluons but you'll
never see them they're hidden inside
other particles and other people like
you you say they're rolling their eyes
and but now yes we've more or less
established that's what happens not not
to the level of a rigorous mathematical
proof but our level of understanding has
increased uh enormously even though what
we're saying is yes those guesses back
in the 70s were correct
right i mean what i do tell my students
is that
still really proving it at the level of
a
sort of paper and pencil mathematical
proof
uh is a subject of one of the so-called
clay prizes
uh you can collect i believe it's a
million dollars maybe the amount has
changed over time i'm not sure uh you
can collect a million dollars if you
show up with
with a proof that
that's been out there for about i guess
20 years or so
and uh it hasn't happened yet so we're
still relying very reliant on
uh very elaborate numerical studies
computer studies for which you know it's
sort of like you know
someone tells you this they did this big
computation and this was the answer and
you don't have a lot you physicists
would like i mean all of us would like
to have some
uh
some simple conceptual understanding of
what's going on right
and
when i say simple i don't you know i
should be careful a little bit i mean
you know you know i i sort of try to
explain both there's a notion of simple
uh which uh is um
uh
uh which you know sometimes we think
about simple as you know quickly i can
give you an answer there's a notion of
simple in the sense that i could give
this as a problem to a very good
graduate student and they could take
them three weeks and they would come
back with an answer that's something i
would call support
as opposed to something which you have
to
spend a lot of time years of your life
and millions of dollars of computer time
and equipment and so on
to solve
so there's a there's a notion of complex
complex or difficult which is which is
sort of technical which is you know
saying
it's not just being smart or being
clever
it's being it you know you needing some
serious resources to solve well i like
to give the podcast episode uh audience
uh some homework so if any of them want
to prove
uh analytically that quarks are confined
in the strong interactions they would
win a million dollars and maybe they
could donate some of that to uh to the
podcast so so now they're they've been
uh informed of that but i guess what i'm
wondering is uh since we're here to sort
of think about how to move forward in
particle physics
we have these three phases
uh the strong the weak and the and the
electromagnetic interactions all
look different to us it took us a while
to figure them out uh so number one are
there other possible phases that quantum
field theories could be in uh that we
just didn't get lucky enough to see in
the real world and number two should we
be surprised in any way
that the three forces that we have in
the standard model are all very
different
um
both are good questions and i'm not sure
i have a good answer
i would be hesitant to say that there
can't be other phases i mean there are
things that
we've learned about quantum field
theories that are uh surprising and
there's surely more to learn i mean
looking you know my colleagues
who
in condensed matter physics and those
who follow condensed matter physics
certainly
there are
phenomena there that that i won't claim
i have much understanding of or
knowledge of uh which are which are
different yeah and whether some of these
could have realizations
in
the kind of quantum field theories that
obey the principles of einstein and and
so on i i'm not i'm not sure i'm
competent to say okay um
the
uh i don't think if i look at the kind
of uh
range of ideas that are out there for
new physics beyond the standard model i
don't know that there's
well i should be a little careful there
i mean i think there are probably people
who talk about
other sorts of phases they might be
varying of things we know
so i should probably be a little careful
there but most of those ideas sort of
fall within within the realm of this
phase as we we know
now whether
uh the question you ask about whether
it's surprising that
uh that the
laws of nature
that we know encompass these three
possibilities
um
it probably gets back to the first part
of the question because it could be that
yes
isn't that amazing there are three
possibilities and they're all exploited
by the laws of nature and uh it could be
well there are three possibilities we
know because there are three
possibilities that are realized in
nature and in the experiments we
understand
well that's so that it leaves us with a
good open question then i guess speaking
of which um back to 2012 when we found
the higgs boson at the lhc
um
i know that a lot of people
certainly me probably you
uh were anticipating finding a lot more
things at the lhc
um were you surprised that we haven't
yet already uh you know
how much of a
realistic expectation was it that we
would find not only the higgs boson but
other particles as well
well this gets to
i i should say in my own career i went
through phases on this question
so if you'd asked me this question uh 20
years ago
i would say oh almost for sure we're
going to find something new and i had a
list of possibilities
so supersymmetry something called
technicolor
and the reason was connected with this
thing called the hierarchy problem which
i don't know if we'll talk about a
little bit but but uh so we had a
particular reason
uh and it's related again to the fact
that the the simple higgs model was just
in some ways too simple it was
it's very hard to understand
why
if there's just the higgs particle the
standard model it's
as light as it is now that's a little
weird because of course it's very heavy
and took
several billion dollars worth of
equipment to
to find it
but really uh it's hard to understand
why it isn't orders of magnitude hard
harder to fight
and
um
and there but and what but what we were
aware of what we became aware of in the
early 2000s is that there's another
puzzle of this nature and this is the
thing that gave me pause about the
hierarchy problem
and this takes us to the to gravity
as you as you alluded this other force
which plays obviously such a big role in
our very existence uh
that
so in gravity there's in einstein's
theory so i'm thinking of gravity as
described in your wonderful textbook in
einstein's gravity there is a
possibility of something called a
cosmological constant
this is something einstein contemplated
early on
when he first started started to think a
little bit about the universe as a whole
and
thought about including it
then with hubble's measurements of the
expansion of the universe discarded it
uh
called it the greatest stake of his life
something like that
uh
and but in fact we know it's there
and we know it's there
in some
well a large amount in the scale of our
universe today it's 70 percent or so of
the energy of the universe
but a very tiny amount compared to what
you might guess it would be a priori
and the truth of the matter is we don't
have any great ideas for
an explanation for this fact
okay it's certainly one of the things
that i view as and most of us view as
one of the great puzzles in physics
it's something which by
uh
the early part of the millennium we had
measured
we i mean of course the humanity
collected right not not you and i i know
yeah and um and
uh and it's very puzzling and this fact
that there's this other puzzle which in
many ways it has some of the same
characteristics of the puzzles of the
higgs
certainly gave me pause
and gave me pause that any of the sort
of rational explanations were which were
people were thinking about for one
problem
uh
could
uh
could be could be what we're looking for
in other words we didn't have a good
explanation for one why should we think
we'd come up with a good explanation for
the other
uh and in fact this probably gets to my
uh to your earlier question i think this
is the thought i lost here that uh you
know in some way one of the explanations
that people offer for this is this
so-called anthropic explanation so for
the cosmological consensus
which is that basically
we somehow the universe selects
from possible laws of nature
those laws which permit the existence of
intelligent being
this is a very disturbed i'm not going
to advocate this for this here but just
it's very disturbing
the problem is that for the cosmological
constant it's about the only game in
town it's about the only explanation we
have
okay uh so you could ask well so i start
i certainly was worried before the lhc
turned on
about whether there was something like
that going on for
the uh
for the higgs phenomena for this
question of the hierarchy problem
getting back to your earlier question in
fact about why why are there these
three realizations of the gauge
principle of the gauge symmetries
uh in the strong the weak and the
electromagnetic force
that might also have something you know
in common with this it may be that you
know in order that we have a sensible
universe in which we can form
complicated
nuclei is iron carbon and so on we need
the strong force to have some of the
features that it has
and in order that stars evolve sensibly
the weak force has to have some of the
features that it has and so on it's a
very disturbing form of explanation
but it does sort of
but it's precisely because it's
disturbing it raises worries about what
what it is we do and don't understand
and what it is we
can hope to understand i think i mean
let's let's take this seriously because
you put some big ideas on the table here
let me let me try to summarize and see
if if i got it um we have this puzzle
why is the higgs boson so liked or why
is uh the hierarchy problem why is there
a difference in energy scale between
the whatever the higgs boson is doing
what we call the electro weak theory and
higher energies of unification or
gravity uh and most explanations we had
on the table would have predicted new
particles you could see at the lhc and
so we were optimistic but then we
realized there was this other puzzle
that was similar in spirit to the
hierarchy problem namely the
cosmological constant problem why is the
energy of empty space so small and there
you didn't quite say this but correct me
if i'm wrong we didn't have don't have
on hand a bunch of plausible
explanations that would have predicted
other particles or anything the best
explanation we had was this anthropic
idea and that raises the specter that
the anthropic idea is also responsible
for the higgs and wouldn't predict any
new particles
right absolutely you know i should say
you know a lot of people you know
there's a lot of hostility to this
entropic idea and for good reason i'm
very i'm sympathetic to it but it often
starts out by saying this is
unscientific
but what is remarkable is that in fact
at the time that stephen weinberg who
really was the person who sharply
formulated this question for the
cosmological constant or the dark energy
put this forward there was no evidence
no sharp evidence certainly for a
cosmological constant
and he said well
what i would since it's so hard to
explain why it should be small what it
should be is the smallest val is the
largest value consistent
with the existence of intelligent
observers and he he didn't do it in
terms of people he did it in terms of
formation of structure of stars and
galaxies
so so he put for he actually made a
prediction
and the prediction wasn't
perfect numerically but it wasn't too
far off yeah uh
in in in a sense again i try and sort of
describe this in the book in a sense
which
is actually remarkably good so so he
made a prediction and the prediction was
verified so it sure looks scientific to
me
it may be wrong
it may it may make us
ill
but but but it's uh but it's it's really
there i mean i i should say in terms of
my expectations i think one of the
things i talk about a little bit in the
book is the
uh is when i first when i first
confronted this question of the
cosmological constant so this was thanks
to leonard suspended stanford
and foreign
yeah and we it was time we were working
on
i was working with a colleague willie
fischler on supersymmetric models to
explain the hierarchy problem
and we had succeeded in various ways
which were new
in making models of this
type so we were very excited we thought
we'd solve the problem and lenny came up
to us and basically said well what about
this cosmological constant issue
and i never thought about it before and
i should say by the way it was lenny who
introduced me as i also explained in the
book to the hierarchy problem
so it's like uh
so
so again i was sort of sort of shaken
and
so willie and i said well we better
solve the cosmological constant problem
so we banged our head for you know a few
weeks as if that was enough yeah and
it's harder to do too successful
but uh but uh
but certainly this as a linger as a as
an issue
so so it's obviously first of all the
issue is not original with me certainly
uh and uh as
as a lingering issue has been
around for you know again the better
part of 40 years
uh yeah i mean maybe let's let's get on
the table what you need to make the sort
of anthropic solutions work right i mean
your you're you're asking a lot and this
is part of i'm i'm willing to consider
anthropic solutions myself although i
share your your maybe not even disdain
but sort of disappointment that we can't
get a unique solution to these things um
but you need kind of a multiverse a lot
of different possibilities out there and
then you look for the little subset
where people can live
right so so in a sense this is the way
the
you know
you could start with the principle and
say you know you can imagine there's an
omnipotent being
that you know
you know wants to great great people and
so
adjust the loss of nature with some
dials and so on until people pop out
but that's not that's certainly not a
very satisfying
form of explanation for most of us i
think even for people who are religious
and so on that's too much
the uh the uh
what
so what weinberg
had in mind was something like the
possibility that there is this
multiverse that there are many possible
universes
what exactly that means i is a question
that you probably understand better than
i and probably don't understand that
well either right
the uh but but in some sense there's
some multiple multiplicity of universes
and that somehow we can sample them okay
and that in some of those most of those
there won't be
as weinberg says in most of those there
won't be
stars or galaxies much less people
okay
in some very small subset he said there
will be there you will grow structure
you will develop
the galaxies stars
planets and so on uh
you once you open this pandora's box you
start worrying about other things you
know when do you have when do you have
carbon-based life
uh you know you you it gets kind of
scary and and and it does run it does in
some sense run the risk of becoming
unscientific in the sense of how do you
how do you decide what what does the
sample look like
so weinberg did something very crude and
simple and and
in its way rather compelling
if you open up as when you open up this
box it gets a little scary i mean how
you actually
and and i have to confess i
i'm guilty of trying to figure out what
it might look like and it's a you know
and it's it's a tough problem yeah
and so is it plausible so it's very
not i shouldn't say very clear but it's
relatively
transparent to me how
if the energy of empty space were
radically different it would be hard for
us to live hard to get stars and
galaxies but what about the higgs boson
that's the other problem is there any
sense in which if the higgs boson were
as heavy as we think it should be
life couldn't exist or is that a more
subtle kind of argument that presumably
depends on what you mean by
life and complexity and atoms and so
forth
well it's
it's possible that
um
you know already processes and stars
are sensitive to
features of the weak interactions which
are for which the higgs particle is the
he and the higgs phenomenon or the
controlling feature
so if the higgs particle were extremely
heavy
uh in the way we we think it it
by right should be then arguably the
the particles which mediate the weak
force would be massless like the photon
and they would
uh and they would not mediate the sort
of
interactions we see in the weak
interactions so they would not involve
processes that change protons into
neutrons and neutrinos and electrons for
example the things that the weak
interactions do
which are
very critical to the way stars burn and
evolve
so um there are people who have thought
more seriously about this than i have
but but it but but i think you could
start you start with processes in stars
and even before you get to people just
the burning and stars and so on would be
would be quite different whether you
could you could sustain stars or not
under what circumstances
uh
i i you need somebody with a with a
better astrophysicist than me probably
you
better me
to sort of enumerate the possibilities
but a lot of them don't come close to
anything like the universe we would see
we see around us
so i guess this was probably
oversimplifying because i had not
thought about this deeply myself i'm a
little skeptical when people
try to pretend they know a little bit
more than they do about what counts as
life and complexity and intelligence and
so forth but but i guess if there were
this kind of mechanism it would be you
know we need some amount of complexity
in the fundamental interactions of
particle physics to give rise to
complexity of big macroscopic systems
and we have that in the standard model
be in part because we have three
different forces that behave in three
different ways no i think you put that
very well and maybe that's like the
minimum you need and maybe that's maybe
that's therefore not surprising that
this is what we see
yeah no i think i think you put that
very well better than i put it before
the the i think about there was
you know this notion of carbon-based
life for example is i remember there's a
was a sort of
a half joke
years and years ago of carl sagan's
about maybe would land on mars and we
would see silicon giraffes i think we're
roughly direct like that
so you know so certainly when you know
so that's just within
kind of thinking about the complexity
you might develop within chemistry as we
know it
and who knows about chemistry as we
don't know
so
uh but i think you're i think you put it
well that that that the the three forces
we have
do
provide somehow a framework which allows
for very complex
structures
uh the sorts of things that might be
necessary for life
is when you get into this entropic
kind of story
i should say by the way in some sense
people you know make fun of it and so on
there's a certain level which is really
a lot of fun
let's let ourselves kind of intriguing
what what are what are the alternatives
you might imagine what are you willing
to
to contemplate i mean so on the one hand
it does take you out of the quickly take
you out of the realm of something you
can sensibly ask scientific questions
about
you know in the sense of
go out and do an experiment let's check
this
but uh but it but it is it is
interesting i i do think of it as kind
of like a resource for homework problems
for students or something
with that in mind and i i think actually
you know we sketched out a plausible
story it's not it's not that crazy but
maybe it's not right either so obviously
as good scientists we want to think
about the alternatives uh so let me get
your ideas about what might be going on
just beyond the standard model that
might be experimentally accessible in
some ways and and i'll let you say what
you actually think but first let me ask
some sort of obvious questions you know
we have families of particles we have
the electron and it's neutrino we have
the muon is neutrino the talon is
neutrino likewise for the quarks
could there be families beyond what we
see we have three generations could
there be a fourth generation of
particles
um
well
we have some constraints on that
so
so the answer is yes with some butts or
or or
asterisks
so
it's probably not if there's a fourth
generation it's probably not exactly
like the other three
so we have some constraints on the
number of neutrinos for example so
probably any neutrinos in a fourth
generation would have to be heavy i
should say by the way maybe back up and
say in a generation as
sean said there are two types of quarks
there are
uh there is a charged lepton like the
electron or
and a neutrino and that repeats that
structure repeats so we have the up and
down the electron and its neutrino we
have the charm cork and the strange
quark and the muon and its neutrino and
we have the bottom and top quarks
the
towel uh
the tau lepton and
its neutrino so those are the three
generations we have we probably can't
repeat exactly that but could there be
others absolutely and so for example in
string theory the kinds of things people
do and they're sort of gains that people
play they're not really
predictive in a reliable sense
but uh it's often they're more
okay and
but but some of these things you really
have to be well hidden or they disrupt
the phenomena we know in astrophysics
and cosmology for example
so uh so there are there are things we
know
uh but they also there are also things
about particles we know the properties
of the of the z boson one of the weak
interacting gauge bosons we would be
disruptive if there are more neutrinos
but
um
but what i'm
one of the things i i i one of the
places in the book where i sort of dared
to make some statements is one of the
extensions of the standard model that
people have talked a lot about is
supersymmetry
and one of the disappointments and it's
certainly i i checked it with some point
or rather i made i may have been given
the number in the book there are
thousands of papers with super symmetry
in the title it's been a big industry
uh and just and i'm certainly was
certainly a participant in much of that
and
and i will defend what i did there
but uh but one of the disappointments
for those who advocated supersymmetry
super symmetry was something which among
other things was
what did several things it was provided
a possible solution to the hierarchy
problem
it it offered an explanation of the dark
matter
uh and it offered some possible
explanation of the strength of the
forces
so it was quite remarkable you should
tell us you should tell us what super
symmetry is
okay good i should back up
so in uh so
in
this is related to this story i told
about lenny suskin the hierarchy problem
the cosmological constant problem
um one of the the question
it's really is sort of why is that again
is what is why is that single higgs
boson there to sort of hanging out by
itself it really has almost no right to
be around and to be as light as it is
and so one of the explanations was maybe
there's a symmetry principle maybe
there's a grand principle
that says the higgs boson can't be too
heavy
and supersymmetry was going to was the
candidate for that principle so what so
first of all was it what what does it
mean to be a boson okay a boson is a
particle with
integer spin either zero spin or spin
one like the photon for example
some the graviton and einstein's theory
would have spin too
okay uh so
particle with integer spin a fermion or
particles like the electron the neutron
the proton particles of half integers
spin and which are distinguished by the
fact that they obey the poly exclusion
principle
and bosons obey a different set of rules
okay developed by bose and einstein
and
uh and and these bosons are puzzling the
gauge boson's not so much so but the
higgs boson yes the particles of spin
zero yes now what
now it turns out that particles with
half integer spin don't create this
puzzle that they can be light with no
problem so this is a feature of quantum
field theory something that's well
understood people thought about this
issue already in the 30s
uh the uh so that part's well understood
so
so what supersymmetry was was a symmetry
between
the particles with half integer spin and
the particles of integer spin
okay and the fact that the half integer
spin particles could be light meant also
that the particles with
uh integer spin could be light and in
particular the higgs boson okay how
light well it turns out about as light
as the
gauge bosons of the weaker directions
the w and c
okay maybe a bit heavier okay and so
that was the reason that was
sort of why
a lot of us thought you should we
actually a lot of us thought you should
see the higgs boson before we built the
lhc
okay got a little worried that it hadn't
been found but said okay maybe it'll be
found there
and it was found there okay but the
supersymmetry the stuff that comes with
it was not found
okay
and that's really um
was really troubling
okay uh and uh and basically what
what we would say is that in order to
understand if the higgs particle i'm
sorry if the particles associated with
supersymmetry the partners of for
example the w and z bosons which would
be some heavy fermions if they are
as heavy as they have to be now we as we
know from looking for them from the lh
from the lhc at the lhc
uh if they're that heavy
that means that there's something
peculiar about the theory that numbers
and the theory the constants the the
constants of nature that control that
theory
have to be adjusted in just the right
way
to make this work so you so if you like
if you're
old ol as old as me and you have you can
remember radios with dials which you
adjusted you have to adjust them to
extreme precision right to get things to
come out so that's the problem
uh now
uh
so what i want one thing that i
think is maybe true is maybe
that's okay
maybe the particles are there and
they're just a little heavier and one of
the reasons i i give for this has to do
actually it's related to this multiverse
picture
okay so in the multiverse one of the
things that's that's interesting about
multiverse
multiverse again is very troubling idea
but it's also really interesting
the yeah and one of the things that's
interesting is that these units you have
universes with
very different energies
and higher energy
states higher energies now this is
energy per unit of volume higher energy
states can decay just like particles can
just like atoms can to lower energy
states that's it and so now you have a
question you have all these states why
are why are they stable
why are they why do they live a long
time they have to live a very long time
the age of our universe is enormous
compared to times the time it takes
light to cross an atomic nucleus for
example which is a kind of
characteristic time we might think about
and so why would that be
and it actually is very hard to come up
with a robust
explanation that sort of explains
why among these many things that for
example our universe could decay to many
many different lower universes lower
energy universes why can't we decay to
any of them well why does it take so
very very long time to decay
and about the only explanation that
really works well and is really
kind of
robust is supersymmetry so supersymmetry
it turns out this is probably this may
be something in your textbook somewhere
it is something that protects
that that protects these states now
supersymmetry would not be exact because
the partner of the electron for example
is
at least too heavy to see at the lhc
okay so supersymmetry is a broken
symmetry but it turns out that's good
enough that the universe could live
for a very very long time if that were
the case
and i so i have sort of speculated that
maybe super we've just been a little
unlucky
super symmetry is sort of around the
corner a bit higher than where we
thought it would be
and i think i i think that well
you know
you know this sounds like it certainly
sounds like making excuses and it is
um i think this is one one possibility
and whether
what's interesting is to ask
there is one handle i should say on this
number which is the mass of the higgs
particle itself
so um if if nature is supersymmetric
given the mass of the higgs particle we
sort of know where supersymmetry should
be
roughly
and it's possibly within reach just
barely of the highest energy
accelerators that people talk about for
the future
so
so in other words not to be too unfair
about it but to simplify
many people who like super symmetry and
especially as an explanation for the
hierarchy problem did expect to
have discovered supersymmetry by now at
the lhc but that hasn't happened um it
could have happened already and what
you're saying is there's still sensible
reasons to think that if we keep looking
we might find it
i i think that's right now
now you know this is a lot to ask of
people
the general public to
you know to fund some international
scale
10 billion dollar plus scale project to
to do this
and for scientists to
devote years and years of their lives
to a search with no guaranteed outcome
so
so
so i don't want to overstate this case
i'm not i don't want my friends to go
out
or come back to you know well you know
by the time they come back to me i won't
be here anymore
but uh but i don't want my friends to go
out
and work so hard to for for
uh in a pursuit which is not
by no means guaranteed or probably
doesn't even have high probability of
success
uh but
um but i do think uh i do think this is
a possibility
uh
i i uh
yeah i mean i'll just leave it at that
okay yeah it's uh it's uh
well i know that supersymmetry is is the
most popular probably uh
theory or framework for going beyond the
standard model but let me let's just
check off some of the others so that
people out there know how they stand and
we talked about it's difficult to add
new generations of particles what about
new le layers right you know we
discovered that protons and neutrons are
made of quarks is it possible that
quarks and leptons are made of even
tinier particles
uh it's certainly certainly possible
it's challenging to build theories of
that kind
and i think
i've developed a sort of prejudice about
that class of ideas
uh
largely uh from thinking about string
theory
so one of the so so string theory is
is really probably in some sense a class
of theories
of elementary particles of strong weak
electromagnetic and gravitational forces
but and we can ask sort of what's but
but but it is remarkable
it hangs together really well
uh in certain at least in certain ways
and
a lot of the problems that we see
uh
when we try and combine general
relativity and the standard model or
resolve
um there are lots of questions that are
not well answered and again i'll
advertise my book for that in terms of i
think talking honestly about what
some of the issues are but at the same
time uh there it is kind of a
template for what an ultimate theory
might look like
and
and it has and it really does have
things like quarks and leptons engage
bosons the things we see it often has
other stuff
that's probably good
but because we we need other stuff to
explain other resolve other questions
but it doesn't
in any obvious ends point to something
like further substructure yeah okay now
that doesn't and that plus the fact that
it's hard to build theories with further
further substructure
uh
you sort of
prejudices me i guess a little bit
against that could it be absolutely but
okay but i mean let's let's stress that
you're giving two very different
sets of reasons for why you're not uh
enthralled by these theories one is that
you have a
belief that we should give a lot of
credence to the possibility that
something like string theory is is
behind the whole story and string theory
does not lend itself but the other one
is a purely empirical thing that uh
given what we know about the data in
particle physics it's just hard to build
models with this kind of substrate yeah
it yes so
this is a point
uh the second point which is different
is it was a point that was uh originally
sort of formulated clearly by gerard
again a long time ago in the late 70s
when people were speculating that you
know well they're quarks and they're
leptons why shouldn't their quarks be
built up yeah other things prions they
were called other kinds of names
uh and um and
it took put forth a set of guiding
principles for such a program
so basically he said the puzzle is
why are when you when you put things
together
why do you get things that are
light or without mass altogether
so things like light things like the
neutrino or relatively light things like
the electron because they have to be
held together very tightly in a very
small space
and heisenberg's uncertainty principle
basically tells you that if things are
squeezed that close together they tend
to have a lot of energy and therefore a
lot of mass
so
so so it took put forth a kind of
guiding principle to how you might
explain this and i think and i think we
still live with that we do not have a
an easy work around and the and it turns
out that this is this constrains things
very tightly it's very hard
to build theories that satisfy these
rules that it took laid down
now could he be wrong
could he have been wrong could there be
a clever solution that we haven't
thought of all that could be true but
sort of my prejudice comes from people's
rather exhaustive efforts to try and
satisfy these constraints or to
understand why they maybe aren't don't
operate why they're not operative
somehow
good i think that that's a sensible
reason to at least not be enthusiastic
until someone comes along with a
brilliant theory right that satisfies
all the constraints etc uh and the other
idea i want to get on the table was
grand unification right we've unified
weinberg and salam unified
electromagnetism with the weak force
it's an obvious thing to try to do to
unify those in some real sense with the
strong force uh people tried it's not
that hard to write down models right no
evidence that any of those models are is
actually correct as yet
right well so this is this is a story uh
this is a whole nother story it's a
story i should say i i i a story i love
uh
in
not so much in this book but in my
textbook i spend a lot of time on it
uh it's just it's incredibly
rich so the this was first really laid
out as a program
by george i and glashow in the 70s 1970s
who said let's you know who basically
picked up math books and said how can we
make the mathematics of the strong weak
and electromagnetic force as it was
coming to be understood how can we put
that in some kind of unified structure
and they wrote something down really
beautiful with remarkable features so it
has a prediction of
one of the
strength of the interactions
uh it has a prediction that
the proton is not stable that's an
unstable radioactive particle that we're
all ultimately radioactive and doomed
uh
fortunately
a long time a long time
but
but uh but and and that opens up a way a
whole other area of under a way of
understanding how we got here in the
first place why there is why there can
be
how you can start with the universe
which doesn't have a
doesn't have matter it doesn't have what
we call barium number
and
develop one with marian number so
so
they so there was a prediction they
predicted that the lifetime of the
proton was something like 10 to the 28th
years
and people went down and mines this is
in the spirit of sending uh
experiments you should or shouldn't send
your friends off to do
uh so they went so 10 to the 28 years is
is an interesting number
because if you think about a tank of
water
a tank of water can easily have 10 to
the 33 or 10 to the 35 or something
atoms in it
so it has a lot of protons which can
decay and so if you sit there for a year
you should be able to see a lot of
decays so people went down deep into
mines and they looked and they didn't
see
uh and the the but the story was really
quite interesting
and then uh cam along came super
symmetry super symmetry predicted well
either the lifetime was much longer with
shorter which wasn't good
or what or was uh somewhat longer so
people again went down in mines and
they're still down there
but the lifetime of the proton is now
known to be
longer than is comfortable for these
theories
and
uh and i think most of us believe that
the proton is is not stable
we even within the standard model it's
not really stable but it lives a very
long time
but the
but whether we'll be able to see it is
is not known but this is but but this is
certainly a set of ideas which are
they're mathematically very beautiful
they're conceptually really beautiful
uh experimental
with sharp experimental prediction
uh and so they're really quite
fascinating another aspect of these
theories which is quite fascinating is
that they predict the existence of
magnetic monopoles which is
so that's something also when you take
your first electrode
electricity and magnetism you learn
about maxwell's equations and you learn
that the second of maxwell's equations
tells you there's no no there are no
magnetic models okay and
dirac sort of figured out a workaround
and that is beautifully realized
in these grand unified theories so so
i'm a big fan
uh i should say that that structure kind
of fits neatly within string theory
again so it's kind of uh
with all these features
so
uh
so
it might be part and parcel or the same
story it might be something on its own
uh it's
the fact the non-observation the fact we
haven't seen proton decay is
uh is
certainly a problem for these ideas in
in most of the
simple implementations which people have
put forward i think it's interesting
that you're using or appealing to two
big ideas about theory choice about what
to be interested in so of course
obviously we'd like our theories to be
verified by data but when you don't know
what the data says and you're deciding
which theories to take seriously
uh you mentioned two big ideas that are
that are important important enough to
raise to a more explicit level one is
that
all of these uh in particle physics
especially when you add new particles or
whatever it affects everything like it
spills off into everything the z boson
is going to change its decay rate if you
add new uh generations of neutrinos the
if there are prions or something like
that that's going to affect the
interactions of particles so it all
hangs together and that really limits
you in what theories you can sort of
take seriously and the other idea is
that
we want our theories to hang together
not just not just the data see you know
the prion ideas don't fit comfortably
with super symmetry and string theory
whereas the grand unification ideas do
fit well and it's perfectly legitimate
to therefore give a little bit more
credence to them
yeah
i'm i i obviously this is
you know reflects
levels of
of prejudice and perhaps hubris uh you
know
a century from now if people are still
looking at these questions
i'm sure they will laugh at us for many
of the things that we do but i think
i think you know we have to make some
choices
and
uh and
um
choices about what we think is possible
where we invest our energies
experimentalists and
uh and um
[Music]
so uh so yes they're they're you know
you know supersymmetry for example
has turned out to be
a rich subject independent of whether it
has anything to do with nature
so it turned in so for example so so as
i mentioned there are questions in the
strong interactions that are keeping me
up up night and some of these are
related
so for example um
there are feature there are features of
the strong the feature of the strong
interaction
that it confines quarks
is a very hard problem for the strong
indirections as they actually are
for a supersymmetric version of the
strong interactions it's not such a hard
problem it's a tractable problem yeah
and you can make definite statements you
can do the math and there are other
features of the strong interactions that
are that are mimicked that way
i'm sort of involved at the moment in a
kind of debate with people about whether
or not you can extend the
supersymmetrical results to
non-supersymmetric cases how how or to
what extent you can make those kind of
statements which sliders do you want
just to say that that certain sub
and
there's uh
there you know i i people have spoken
about this i guess uh
uh you know their their books about this
about the the the the temptations of
math beautiful mathematics
uh and and that's that that subject is
real but that that that that's a real
thing
but uh but but there is physical insight
that comes from from understanding some
of these theories
the uh but but but uh but there's a
there's certainly a good deal of hubris
or potential for for this in
in in how you make it how you make these
choices
uh and a little you know i say a little
bit just depends on you we have finite
amount of time to yeah
to to investigate things and where we
choose to look okay
is
you know i say a story i like to tell
one of my mentors as a graduate student
was a
physicist named feza gerstein
who was a he was
turkish originally uh
he was a wonderful person he was
very mathematically inclined he loved
beautiful mathematics
he seemed in some ways to be sort of a
dreamy
theorist if you like
but i remember his he took me out to
lunch one day early in my career
and encouraged me to to do theoretical
physics and he talked about something he
called good taste
and this is and this is precisely for a
theorist the question of how you choose
problems to work on
uh and
and the truth of the matter is he
probably was not in the way people use
the term the the the the epitome of good
taste but he knew what it was yeah there
you go
and he told me what i should do
and
you know it was a wonder it was a very
memorable and it's a wonderful
conversation i mean the way i would put
it is because i think we're probably
pretty closely aligned on these things
beauty and elegance and sort of
mathematical
prettiness of a theory doesn't mean the
theory is right uh but given two
competing theories that neither one of
which we know is right or wrong
why would you spend too much time on the
ugly one if you had if you had a
prettier one that you could spend time
on
yeah i mean this in some ways gets back
you know
in in an ugly way actually gets back
there may be a justification for
simplicity in beauty and that's and that
again gets to this question of the
anthropic principle right so um so the
anthropic principle would sort of
suggest
that the simplest realization of
of some possibility that leads to
whatever it is we want planets stars
carbon
uh is the most likely because you're
selecting among a vast array of things
and
and
you know more complicated things that do
all the things you want will be more
exceptional
so
so so in some sense this gets back to my
statement about the higgs boson so it
was one of the reasons for my statement
before
if we need a higgs boson to have
life
okay we only need one
it's hard to get one yeah much harder to
get to
so
so as i say i think so so what was so i
would say that for example the discovery
of a second hinge boson at the lhc for
that to happen
would be a strong evidence against some
kind of
anthropic explanation of the strength of
the weak force
so
so there's a a
if you like a
possibly complicated and ugly
explanation for simplicity no actually i
really really like that i want to sort
of emphasize that because
uh if you contrast the anthropic versus
super symmetry explanations for the
higgs boson uh super symmetry naturally
comes along with several higgs bosons
right right and because there's a
dynamical mathematical mechanism that
makes a prediction whereas in the
anthropic case you're just saying that
the only reason this number is so tiny
is because we wouldn't be here otherwise
and so it kind of will end up looking
unnatural from our point of view and so
there's this is an experimental we're
updating our credences as we look for
new particles and don't find any more
higgs bosons
yeah i mean i i kind of ugly sort of
story that that i've occasionally
contemplated for
how super symmetry might end up being
you know a little beyond where we expect
is suppose it is anthropic supposed
super symmetry itself the scale at which
it breaks
is anthropic
but suppose there's some other issues
but in addition to the strength of the
weak force suppose also there's for
example some feature of the dark matter
which is important
for
formation of galaxies in our existence
and suppose somehow that selects
somewhat
larger scales of supersymmetry breaking
so it somehow scales so the so suppose
the dark matter comes from the particle
these extra particles of supersymmetry
as it
as people have suggested
but suppose somehow that uh that these
things need to be a bit heavier than we
guessed
you know maybe maybe that pushes things
up a bit and then we would find these
other higgs
for example at this higher scale as well
as some of these these other partners
yeah so so there could be a kind of uh
hybrid story
um
and you know as i say i mean getting
back to anthropics i mean you know this
this argument that maybe there's some
kind of supersymmetry anthropically
because the universe has to live a long
time
uh is uh is an example of philanthropic
argument it doesn't it doesn't predict
necessarily by itself that
uh that we should be that super synergy
is around the corner supersymmetry just
has to be
it could be quite a high scale just
can't be extremely extremely high let me
just because i think that i'm
i don't exactly uh
maybe i'm not as familiar as i should be
with this particular argument um is the
idea so we have the idea that
the
vacuum energy the dark energy the
cosmological constant could have
different values depending on what
different fields in the universe are
doing we have a particular value here
which is positive but low in our
universe
and maybe if with different field
configurations there could be either
lower but still positive or even
negative values of the vacuum energy are
you saying that without super symmetry
we should quickly decay into one of
those either lower but positive or
negative values that's what i'm saying
the i should say by the way i i had some
formulation of this which was which was
off and the person who got me
correctly
situated was edward witt okay and you
know you probably know the story a bit
there's something in in general
relativity called the positive energy
theorem yeah
okay which was proven i guess originally
by yell
for which he won the fields medal
and then whitten came along as a young
postdoc i think
and proved a version of this by sort of
pretending there was supersymmetry
okay and the and basically the reason is
that if you have
if you have a
flat space time of minkowski space
space-time
with supersymmetry
uh then you can prove that the vacuum
energy has to be greater than the zero
greater than or equal to zero
if you break this so uh and that means
that you don't have a lower energy state
you can decay to okay so you can't try
you could try you can't no matter what
your theory looks like otherwise you
can't put together things in a way that
you have some lower energy bubble that
can you conform and that grows and this
which is the way the universe universes
decay
now if you break super symmetry a little
bit then you can ask well what happens
to that
and the answer is that well then you
typically can decay but it takes a long
time
so
um and as i say i i i i think i've
blotted out the original way in which i
formulated this question because it
probably is too embarrassing
but
uh as
thinking straight about this problem
well more evidence it all hangs together
we need we can't just like think about
these issues one by one they do
intersect with each other i one of the
things we're already an hour in but i i
really want to get to some of the
reasons why
modern particle physicists aren't
content with the standard model as a
theory of everything you know um we've
given some examples of ways that we
could potentially go beyond it right but
i want to give more the motivation for
why we think that we're not done yet um
uh let me just name one the matter
antimatter asymmetry right uh we're made
of particles not of anti-particles how
did that happen
so so in fact i should say that these
days the drivers
for a lot of what's going on in
theoretical physics are exactly these
questions or features of
or you know i think people have backed
away a little bit from thinking about
the hierarchy problem for example and
we're thinking more in terms of
observational things we know which we
which we can't resolve within the
standard model
so
the
so i perhaps one there so a couple i've
alluded to but one in particular is the
dark matter
okay
so
uh the dark matter almost certainly
requires
something new
some new laws of nature some new
particles
uh so that's one another is the
as you say the asymmetry between matter
and anti-matter so if you if you unless
you just take that as a given as a
starting point
then within the standard model you can't
explain that fact
uh and again i you know and you know i
sort of tell stories in my book about
this so that the person who first sort
of clearly laid out what you needed what
were the ingredients
for uh matter anti and that matter
antimatter asymmetry really formulated
this question was andrei sakharov
who was a great soviet scientist of
well-known dissident
called the father of the soviet hydrogen
bomb probably not so wonderful
but
in any case he laid this out in the 60s
and he didn't really have a very
plausible framework in which to consider
it the first plausible framework was as
we said was this framework of grant
unification
where people really took off with it and
subsequently other
ideas
about this have arisen
and what what's interesting here
is
or the interesting question you might
ask is
if if any one of these mechanisms so we
have a bunch of plausible mechanisms for
how this might come about can we
distinguish them what are the are there
experimental signatures which we can
hope to see either observational
signatures as we look in the sky or
things we might see in accelerators and
those questions are tough
and are contingent on
other things so for example if we
discovered supersymmetry it opens up
many
possible mechanisms yeah in which this
might arise so that's another one
dark matter as we've said
what is it
is it is it some new type of particle is
it the
uh is it some of these particles
associated with supersymmetry is it
something
i've become i i proposed another
particle known as the axion
which i think in some ways looks better
but it's also yeah but also its
discovery is contingent its discovery is
possible and there are searches that are
going on
experimental searches
but
success is contingent on a number of
unknowns
well let's be a little bit more explicit
about this i mean let's let's take for
granted that people think that there's
dark matter i know that not all of my
audience thinks there is dark matter
some people think it's modifying gravity
but uh if there is
um like you say there's a good reason to
believe that it's not just something in
the standard model we need to go beyond
it somehow
but what are the leading alternatives
for how to get dark matter out of new
particle physics
there are a number of things which
people are looking at i mentioned the
axion the axon is a
idea that originated with uh roberto
pache and helen quinn some time ago
uh
in the 70s that evolved including
including
inputs from myself and my colleagues
willie fishler and mark stretnicki
uh
and
uh others
uh and uh and it's it's it's if it's
right it's something that kind of
emerges from actually thinking about
issues in the strong interactions
uh and
uh
if it's right it's it's a it's it says
the universe is made of the
the
25 20 or so of the energy density of the
universe 25
is in these particles called axions the
name comes from the name of a
detergent which was popular briefly in
the 70s
uh the um
it's a play it's a pun of sorts
uh the um
but uh
and and in the last
decade or so we've we're now in a
position that experiments can have some
realistic chance of seeing it if if
we're a little bit lucky
uh
so so this is one candidate
uh
lately
people have
sort of taken the ideas that people
thought about the framework of super
symmetry where there were these sort of
massive very weakly interacting
particles in fact they were called wimps
for weakly interacting massive particles
so people have taken that that set of
ideas and modified them they've added
additional particles sometimes light
particles sometimes new photon-like
particles
and people have basically opened up an
array of possible explanations
my own feeling about this is at this
point there are so many things that
people talk about
that one in thinking about experiments
one likes to one wants to ask
what
what what
swap of this set of ideas can a given
experiment explore yeah
because because they're not so so
when people first thought about
supersymmetry and dark matter it was
pretty a pretty clean story we thought
we knew what the scale of breaking of
supersymmetry was how massive these
particles had to be we had a sharp
prediction of then of how much dark
matter there was
what we should be looking for
uh and we don't have that at this point
so
so we're a little so we're we're kind of
uh shooting in the dark a little bit so
yeah with the weekly interacting massive
particles we've had
two things right one is that we didn't
see anything uh at the lhc beyond the
ordinary higgs and maybe
part of what we would have seen would
have given us a clue to what such a
particle could have been and the other
is that we've looked directly for weakly
interacting massive dark matter and
haven't found it yet so it's not ruled
out but maybe this gives more
emphasis to the axion idea
no my own prejudices it gives more bread
more emphasis to the accident india and
in fact
so the accident idea so my own again
this is now i'm totally throwing my own
short biosis in here
but the axion idea comes as i said came
originally from thinking about a puzzle
in the strong interactions
a puzzle which is a puzzle of why the
why the forces of the strong why the
strong force
uh isn't the same if you if you make a
movie of some event and
or isn't different rather if you look at
a movie of some event and you reverse in
reverse the video you take that video
and you do it backwards
okay so the laws of nature are
the laws of the strong the strong force
is very nearly the same whether you view
time as going forward or backward
okay uh it's very hard to understand
that fact
okay the the the standard model is
very susceptible to a breakdown of that
relation between the past and the future
and the accent was proposed to explain
that
uh there are other explanations that
have been offered
and
uh
they're really sort of two and i've
spent a lot of time thinking about those
two and thinking about whether they are
as
plausible as the accident idea
and i would claim that they're not
so if the axon is around then you need
it for one thing it might well be
necessary for this other
now beyond that you really need to
discover it
and you're not guaranteed you have to be
a bit lucky
how things work out to be able to
discover it well i think one thing maybe
worth emphasizing is that even if axions
and wimps are two of the biggest
candidates for what the dark matter is
the way that experimentally we look for
them is utterly different in the two
cases no they're very different so they
uh so for example the uh for for the
wimps
for we look for them directly if the
wind if
dark matter is wimps then these things
are passing through the earth all the
time if you go down deep in a mine
okay uh with a very sensitive instrument
you can hope to see these particles you
can hope to see them one once in a while
they they interact very weakly but they
interact some of the time sort of like
neutrinos yeah they interact sometimes
and you ought to be able to see some of
those interactions okay just as you can
see neutrinos from the sun deep in mines
and
uh and that we've looked at as you say
and uh and have not seen
so we've sent set limits on how heavy
they might be
they need to be or how weakly they
interact
okay and these limits are quite strong
they're very
they're very
the theories we have the simple theories
we have don't satisfy
so we need special theories in which
theories with special properties and
which this would be true our sort of
generic ideas certainly don't work
for the axion uh the the story is a
little bit different uh you don't have
to go deep into a mine
but there's still axons all around this
and what you need is a
is a big magnetic field so an axion in a
big magnetic field will convert to a
photon
will turn into a photon a very low
energy photon
okay so you have to have an instrument
that's sensitive a large magnetic field
and an instrument that's sensitive
enough that it can detect this this this
very low energy photon
uh
there are other things that you need you
need because the
because the energy is low it's there's
also a particular energy you're looking
for
and so you need to search in little
increments of energy
okay
very tiny instruments of energy to do
this and so again all this these
problems have been
for an interesting range of possible
masses of the axion have been solved and
there are active experiments and there
are ideas to look at other ranges
so
uh
i'm an advocate of uh
of of a sort of lighter axiom that's
harder to see
and people have put forward proposals
which
open up some of that
some of the some of that possible space
this discussion reminds me of a question
i wanted to ask earlier but didn't um
the original motivation for the axion
wasn't dark matter that was a bonus that
came along it was this
lack of parody violation in the strong
interactions parody the mirror symmetry
but the whole idea of parity in the
standard model is a little bit different
i mean a little bit weird in the sense
that people are originally surprised
that it was violated at all and it's
violated a very interesting way where
the strong and electromagnetic
interactions don't violate parity but
the weak ones do
is that by itself a puzzle or is it just
you know well we had a 50 50 chance of
violating or not violating parity should
we really be concentrating on trying to
explain that or just taking it as as
given
um
it is
it is puzzling in many ways and it is
you know yeah it actually gets back to
um
to
uh
some of our earlier
discussion about you know what you know
why why did the weak the strong weakened
electromagnetic interactions have the
form they have
so um
but it also gets back i mean you know
i've mentioned string theory a couple
times and one of the interesting things
about string theory
uh in its earlier in its earliest
manifestations when people first started
thinking about string theory as a theory
of which incorporated general relativity
was expl the problem of explaining this
fact that there's a that you don't have
this mirror symmetry this parity
symmetry
and
there were very general arguments
largely put forward by ed whitten
that it was very hard to con would be
very hard to construct a string theory
which respect which had this feature
that would know the difference between
left and right
and this the first the so-called first
super string revolution was the
discovery that in fact there are string
theories
that have this feature so so it is a big
deal
um
to get this to to get this asymmetry
uh i should say i mean i you know i in
in
my book i tell
a little bit of the story of the
discovery of the violation of parody
both the theoretical proposal by lian
yang
and the experimental discovery by c.s wu
and there's actually a wonderful op-ed
recently by csu's granddaughter oh yeah
the washington post
about uh her grandmother and her
her discovery and i i felt a certain uh
resonance with uh
with the this uh with with this story
and the way i told it i told some parts
of that story in my own book about the
higgs boson it really is
a fascinating little bit of history but
i mean maybe this is a good um entree
into the final big thought i wanted to
get on the table here we mentioned
string theory a bunch of times how
useful it is
uh but it's also gotten a lot of bad
press uh in the public eye i remember it
must have been ten years ago uh i i
mentioned string theory in a
non-negative way on my blog and an
editor from new scientist said oh i
didn't think that people took string
theory seriously anymore could you
please write an article for us saying
that string theory is still alive and
kicking and this is 10 years ago so uh i
mean maybe for the people out there who
mostly heard the public debate about
this what is your insider's take on
string theory and its current status
uh
it's a good question
there's probably a fast answer and a
long answer the long answer is in a
couple chapters in my book
that's a short answer
is that
string theory i think at the moment from
for many of us and certainly for me
functions as a model of what an ultimate
theory sort of might look like
what actually implementing it as a as a
model of nature
uh
faces many obstacles the subject is a
very active one because
uh because there are first of all there
are many theoretical questions that we
can look at
with
in a very substantive way and i think
that's a lot of where activity is at the
moment so for example stephen hawking
raised questions about the compatibility
of black holes in quantum mechanics
in string theory those questions are at
least partially answered
okay so so his objections should apply
there and they don't
okay
exactly how
string theory invades
is his the the issues he raises
uh that it doesn't i should say that it
does evade them is clear
exactly how it does it is more
mysterious
and it occupies a lot of attention of a
lot of very clever people
so that's one area string theory as uh
as a theory of nature i think
is
there's there's a lot of
there are people who work sort of
actively
trying to to on what they would call a
string phenomenology but i think that
at the moment this is a
this is a hard
topic we just don't understand well
enough
how in detail the theory could be
related to nature the theory is
uh in some ways it's very simple it
postulates the basic objects or strings
strings are rather simple things
but in but the steps from there to
things that look like the standard model
that look like general relativity are
pretty elaborate and along the way there
are
there are steps we don't really
understand
so so it's a
it's a hard problem in the technical
sense of heart and it's a hard problem
in some ways it's intellectually
challenging but it's also a hard problem
that there are steps in that process
that we don't really don't know how to
fill in
and so
so i think as a kind of guide to our
thinking it's it's it remains a quite
rich topic as a source of
understanding of big big questions in
science it's a it's it's a resource uh
that were i don't think we're on the
brink of understanding in any detailed
sense how string theory might explain
the world we see
good i think that's a very fair overview
but let me let me try to be unfair let
me let me give let me ask you how you
respond to sort of the hardcore critics
who who might say something like this in
the 1980s first superstring revolution
people were going around saying like
yeah we're going to unify everything
we're going to predict uh the mass of
the electron everything is going to be
finished in 10 years
then not only has string theory not made
any predictions that you can test an
accelerator but once we have the
landscape of string theory we're saying
that string theory is compatible with
almost any set of particle physics you
can have and at that point shouldn't you
just give up and move on to something
else it's it's not a thing that's going
to give you any testable predictions at
any point in the future
uh well i would basically say that that
all that is fair
and uh
but i
it's some gut level i don't exactly
agree
the
um
so first of all i would say that in in
1985 already
in this era the first super string
revolution nathan cyberg and i pointed
out
what what has been come to be known as
the dine cyborg problem
uh
you know
a very basic and fundamental obstacle
to relating string theory to nature
and people have proposed possible
solutions some of which are interesting
but really there's you know in the
subsequent nearly 40 years
uh there is uh there is there people
have not put forward so i'm on safe
ground i i took i i sort of took both
sides of this issue
uh actually i should say uh lenny lenny
sasuke has this book called the cosmic
landscape
and
he mentions at some point a paper that i
wrote with various colleagues
criticizing the landscape idea but then
in a sort of footnote says well but
dying sort of has come around to
be more more interested
yeah sorry is there is there is there
any way to summarize what the diazepam
problem is
um
again this gets a
few pages in my book
uh it's uh but it's basically the the
problem that
uh
one of the great things about string
theory as a theory of quantum gravity is
that you can calculate things
but you can only calculate things
in unrealistic settings
they're interesting calculations in any
case they're calculations that in
ordinary quantum field theories you
wouldn't know how to do
but they're not
it's not nature
and and the problem is that
and the problem is basically one that
nature
that nature has to be sitting in a place
where the kind of easy calculations to
do can't work right
so that's not as uh an argument that the
theory is wrong but that it's not even
if it's serious right even if it's right
it's gonna be very argument
yeah okay very good i do i do it's hard
and it's hard again in this sense it's
not just
a hard homework problem which keeps you
busy up late one night
it's a hard problem in a sense it's
tough to formulate but okay i mean but
maybe i didn't quite let you finish but
uh
what
why not just give up if we think that uh
string theory could predict anything at
all given the landscape problem
well
i i think what i i i think my own
attitude is to sit somewhere kind of on
the fence
not to devote huge amounts of energy
to it but to allow string theory to
inform my thinking about various kinds
of issues so as an example
uh let me take a more concrete example
this axion idea okay
i talked about the oxygen idea as
opposed to two other ideas for
understanding the strong cp problem this
time reversal problem uh
in in making that assessment i said well
the axon is best but it's only best
modulo one a problem a big problem the
axion had which was pointed out as
stressed by john march russell with mark
kaminkowski for example
many years ago
and that problem
is
solved within string theory
so string theory invades it
and in a way that we can understand
in a way that
whatever
if axion's the accident idea is right
whatever is the underlying theory has to
do something like that
so so this is a case where string so so
i can't say there's a prediction
i don't know because i can't say that
nature that string theory predicts the
world as we see it
but if it predicts more or less the
world is we see it we can understand
this how axions might arise
okay so uh so there are there are um
there are several other examples of that
sort
uh which so so you know so so the one so
for example we mentioned this landscape
idea you know to underst understand if
if
if the landscape idea is to attain some
status as a scientific idea it there
needs to be some kind of
structure
theoretical structure which
accounts for
this bizarre fact that there are many
types of universes
and string theory
we're not sure
but string theory first of all is
probably the only framework in which we
have to even think about the question
and there are some indications that it
might do that that it might there are
ways in which you could see a large
number of possible universes might occur
well okay this this
brings up a different worry about string
theory and maybe this is the final one
um
the sort of conceptual issues related to
quantum gravity right uh we've been
trying to quantize gravity for quite a
long time there are uh small but vibrant
communities trying to do loop quantum
gravity or causal sets or something like
that uh which really are just trying to
do gravity rather than unify everything
at once
string theory is an example where it
came out of particle physics it wasn't
trying to do gravity but gravity sort of
falls into your lap when you do string
theory uh but there's still the the
worry that because of that because the
whole theory started with just asking
about
strings vibrating through a pre-existing
space-time it doesn't tell us much about
the fundamental questions of why there
is space time what the quantum nature of
space-time itself is it you know it
starts by talking about strings moving
through a pre-existing space-time and
therefore doesn't address the conceptual
questions of quantum gravity do you
consider these to be real worries or is
just sort of a uh a hang-up that people
have from thinking about things in a
different way
well i wouldn't describe it as a worry
but i would describe it as true okay
that we don't uh that you know we
started you know certainly the way we
string theory is a structure
is a structure we stumbled on
uh
you know very much like the blind person
in the elephant
you know um you know we you know as i
describe it in the in my book you give
this problem you could give this problem
a certain kind of textbook problem to a
graduate student the grad you know
graduate student can come back in a few
days and tell you they discovered
general relativity
and it's pretty weird there are other
ways to view the theory which are
uh which are quite interesting in which
space time emerges
uh as
well i should say emerges yeah it's the
language people use the condensed matter
businesses use that language now space
time is not the fundamental entity
just a feature that that comes out of
the theory sometimes
and
notable examples of this are
within the so-called ads cft
correspondence of maldasena and the
matrix models of bank shanker
suska and suskin
and fischer
and
um
in which
the things you start with don't look at
any at all like space-time right
uh and
uh
and i think the truth of the matter is
we don't know
you know
one of the things i i sort of like to
say about this is we don't know for
example are there
is string theory many theories or is it
one theory
we don't really know that and similarly
we don't so is there for example one
theory of quantum gravity
of which string theory represents one
realization which we can understand
or is or are there many and these are
things we don't know the answer to
so
this kind of gets back to your question
of should you give up
and the answer is yes and no i think yes
in the sense that tomorrow you're
probably not going to be able to say
this is the way
nature is
but no in the sense that you're learning
a lot about what might ultimately be the
uh the structure which explains the
things we see
so okay i think that leads into what the
final question is uh in terms of
again putting our money where our mouths
are when a young student comes up to you
and a graduate student who wants to
specialize in something and get their
phd and they're deciding between you
know biophysics and astrophysics and
particle theory and they say well i love
the ideas of particle theory it's very
exciting and some of the the ongoing
ideas axions string theory supersymmetry
granulation all sound very exciting but
i'm worried
that the can the the intellectual
situation 30 years from now is going to
be the same as it is today because it's
very hard to make experimental progress
you know what do you tell that young
story-eyed person
well
i think i think i'll refer back to my
book again i think i tried to organize
the kind of questions which basis in
terms of
where i think the you know the most
likely
areas of progress are in the sense of
experimental progress in sense of
theoretical progress
and those things may be different
and
and and my crystal ball is probably not
that great
but
i do think we there are areas in which
we are making progress so for example i
think we will you know on the
experimental side
i think there's a good chance
that in the coming decades we will
figure out what the dark matter is
we will on the theoretical side
we will probably make progress
using tools like string theory and
related ideas in understanding
basic questions about quantum gravity
and how it fits together
so in terms of sorting out what things
one might work on
uh
you know these are these you know i
would certainly urge a student to go
into areas where either on the theory
side or the experimental side there's
some
there are there are uh
prospects for for real
for real progress
uh
there are there aren't there aren't
guarantees and in fact
again i said obviously a little bit in
my book i talk about
you know this question of how you uh
of how you make your mark of how you
might choose in science to
to to to make a
you know lasting contribution
i refer to i refer i tell a story i
refer to the fact that i went back when
students come to me
i often will say to them you should be
so lucky as to be a footnote in the in
the history of science
yeah
and then i very proudly take from my
shelf andre sakharov's memoir where i'm
a footnote oh that's very good
so so that's
you know this is uh i said this is you
know it's it's it's a challenge
certainly
um
certainly
when students really come with that sort
of question it's it's quite serious and
you know and it's their lives
the way they lead their lives that that
that's that are at stake so it's a it's
not it's not uh i don't i don't approach
that lightly i'm very much in favor of
uh aiming for being a footnote in uh the
history of science i think it's an
excellent place to go and uh michael
dyne thanks very much for being very
fair and being very helpful in
understanding where we are right now in
fundamental physics well thank you very
much for having me this has been a
pleasure
[Music]
you